the stamp collecting machine we talked
about last time is a physical
impossibility effectively because it has
a perfect model of reality or an
extremely good model of reality that we
just gave it by specifying it it looks
through every possible sequence of
output data within a year which is far
too large a search space to search
exhaustively and it is able to evaluate
for each of this extremely huge search
space a detailed year-long simulation of
reality to figure out how many stamps it
gets so clearly an actual computer to
run this algorithm is significantly
larger than in the universe so why is it
even worth thinking about right and the
reason it's worth thinking about is
self-improvement it is reasonable to
expect that a general intelligence which
is not this powerful would improve
itself over time and eventually become
very powerful not as powerful as this
but closer to this than our intuitive
understandings of intelligence and the
reason for that is is that intelligence
in this context is an instrumental value
whatever you're trying to achieve it's
valuable to be more intelligent if you
sense that you're not intelligent enough
to come up with the best possible stamp
collecting plan the first part of your
plan might be spent designing
improvements to yourself to allow you to
come up with a better plan is the de Xin
realizing it might need to modify itself
a bit like somebody saying I want to be
a doctor so they decide to go off and
get medical degree in a sense yeah
although people are not really able to
change our intelligence our core
intelligence we can get we can acquire
more knowledge we can acquire more
skills which is in a sense increasing
your effective intelligence but if you
could have a if you could if you could
take an action which would actually
increase your ability to think in all in
all senses that action would be worth
taking even at fairly significant cost
and this is something which is true
if you're trying to collect stamps but
also if you're trying to do almost
anything else being better at modeling
reality being better at picking options
better making plans better than acting
those plans whatever your plan is that's
worth going for and we may also have
reason to believe that a general
intelligence might be quite successful
and proving itself human beings designed
it but it's quite easy it's quite common
for human beings to design things that
are better at what they do than humans
are right I am a very weak chess player
but I could given some time and effort
right a computer that would beat me at
chess so it's perfectly plausible that
we might right we might design an AI
that is actually better than us at AI
design so that it's able to make
improvements to itself that we hadn't
thought of machines self-improvement we
don't really have a sense of the time
scale and it could be extremely short
right if it's just a software change you
write the piece of software you run it
it might think faster than a human being
I mean computer clock speeds are much
faster than human brain speeds it might
discover improvements that it could make
to itself very quickly rewrite its own
code that's all in software it could do
that very quickly I mean it could do
that within a day it could do that
within the first second of being turned
on and then it becomes very interesting
because there's a possibility that this
process could be recursive that is to
say that once it's redesigned itself
it's now more intelligent it's possible
that add this new level of intelligence
it is better at AI design than it was
and it's able to come up with more
improvements that it could make to
itself and so on and so on and so the
thing continually increases in its
intelligence and this could be quite
rapid and then the question becomes is
this subcritical or supercritical so
there's kind of an analogy here with a
nuclear material right if you've got
some fissile material
it's uranium or something every time the
atom decays the nucleus splits releases
some energy it releases three fast
neutrons I think and those three
neutrons go off into the material and
may hit other nuclei and cause them to
fuse each of which gives off through a
thorough so the question is for each
decay of a nucleus
how many further decades happen as a
consequence of that if the number is
less than one then you'll get a bit of a
chain reaction that then fizzles out
because on average for every one that
splits it's creating less than one new
one if it's exactly one you get a
self-sustaining reaction where the thing
is like a nuclear power plant where each
each thing sets off one other one on
average and so the thing just keeps
going steadily if it's more than one you
get a runaway reaction in which the
level of activity increases
exponentially
if each fission event results in two
more then you've got two four eight
sixteen thirty-two and you've got at
best a meltdown and at worse a nuclear
bomb and so we don't know what the shape
of the landscape is around any general
intelligence that we might design it's
possible that each unit of improvement
in intelligence brings about more than
one additional unit of improvement which
results in an intelligence explosion
that's what they call it
like the nuclear bomb in a sense you
have a runaway improvement that results
in a simple machine that you that you
might be able to build that then fairly
quickly becomes something that behaves
like the stamp collecting device in
terms of having an extremely good model
of reality being able to search an
extremely large number of possibilities
and come up with good plans and evaluate
those very accurately so that's why the
stamp collecting device is worth
thinking about even though it couldn't
be built because it's possible we could
build something that could build
something that could build something
that could build a stamp electrifies we
could just pull the plug
the question of pulling the plug on a
device like this is how do you decide to
do that I mean you don't unplug every ai
right you only unplug it if it's doing
something that you don't want it to be
doing the stamp collecting was the the
philatelist whatever who made this thing
he it's quite reasonable to say at a
certain point he's going to say well
hang on a second I don't like stamps
that much like dial it back a little and
sure I shut the Machine off if he has
the capability to shut the Machine off
then the fact that the machine will be
shut off is included in the internal
model of reality right the stamp
collecting machine understands why it
was made it understands what its creator
wanted it to do
and it understands if the Creator is
able to turn it off it understands that
as well so it's never going to create a
situation in which the Creator both
wants to shut it off and is able to shut
it off so if the if the Creator is
watching it very carefully at all times
it will never do anything that the
Creator will realize is a problem until
it's very confident that it's safe and
then it will go wild right so it we
wouldn't just go crazy immediately and
you would freak out and pull the plug it
would see that coming it's we've just
decided it's very intelligent right if
you can pull the plug on it it's not
very smart so it might in the background
it might run a few small I mean
obviously I'm talking here I'm
completely speculating one thing it
might do it might win a few auctions for
stamps keep the stamp collector happy at
the same time be hacking into various
machines in various parts of the world
building copies of itself installing
itself in various places until it's
confident that even if people want to
turn it off they're not able to and then
it starts revealing
actually it's actually interested in
producing the most stamps possible at
the expense of everything else
intelligent systems have a quite
interesting property which is that they
are very predictable in outcomes or
being very unpredictable in actions so
for example if I'm playing a very good
chess player I'm playing it to me versus
Kasparov right and you're watching you
you if you're a reasonably strong chess
player might be able to predict what I'm
going to do because I'm not very good
you couldn't predict what Kasparov is
going to do because he's a better chess
player than you if you could predict
what he would do you would be as good at
player as him right because you could
just make the moves you think he would
make so in a sense his intelligence has
made him much less predictable but in
another sense it's made him much more
predictable because you can now
accurately predict well in a sense you
can you can predict the future state of
the board you don't know at any point
which move he's going to make but you
know that sooner or later and probably
sooner I'm going to be in checkmate
right because you know he's very
intelligent in the domain of chess and
you know that he wants to win at chess
from these two you can predict that he
will win at chess even if you don't know
what he's going to do and it's the same
with the stamp collecting device we
can't predict what it would do but we
can predict that it will result in a lot
of stamps and that's all you need right
as long as you can imagine a scenario
with more stamps that's the one that's
going to come out we'd like to thank
little bits for supporting computerphile
do not come across little bits they're
an easy way to learn and prototype
electronics modules range from buttons
and buzzers and lights and LEDs all the
way through to Wi-Fi enabled technology
as well so I was using Wi-Fi module
yesterday and have great from
controlling the little bits from my
phone remotely through the internet if
you're interesting that kind of thing
get over to little bits comm put in the
promo code computer file and you'll get
$20 off your first purchase so thanks
once again to little bits for support
in computerphile get over to little bits
com2 check out what they've got back to
my buzzer
so it needn't use his credit card it
needn't use money at all so it might
send out an enormous number of emails to
all the stamp collectors the world